that's next hey matt stephen's going to
be investing in you i hope you like that
what's up man that sounds good to me
so what's up how can we help so i just
don't have a general question related
um i always have an argument with my
wife exactly how much we're able to
spend on
you know things to enjoy our lives like
vacations and like
uh you know i like to golf and i like to
you know i'm more of a spender um like
going out to eat things like that
so we're pretty well off are you out of
debt
no doubt yeah okay and you have an
emergency fund
yeah yeah and what's your household
income
uh maybe about like 2 20 to 2 30.
and what are you wanting to budget for
entertainment and golf and what is she
saying
she wants to so i guess
uh i mean it kind of varies obviously i
don't golfing
okay there's your problem you're making
this crap up as you go you're not
agreeing to anything and she sees this
as an infinite bottomless pit
you just want to spend what you want
when you want to right yeah
i mean basically a child you have to put
it on paper
i don't care what the amount is but you
got to put it on paper the fact that
you're not willing to put a number down
and stick to it
that's what's scaring her it's not the
number it's scaring me too by the way
stephen too because he's investing in
you
yeah i i mean again we i'm not like you
know irrational about it but like yeah
i think i guess you're right yeah you
are because you're not willing to put a
limit on it you're not in congress you
have to put a limit on it you feel you
feel like a budget is restrictive
yes or no i don't know i mean a little
bit considering that
you know again i i don't you know the
way i feel i spend my money i don't
overdo it but i guess
things right i don't really all you
gotta do is put a number on it you see
the plan
you might be surprised that what she
would agree to in the in terms of the
number if you put a number to it
and you agree that there is a point at
which you look at yourself in the mirror
and you say no
enough already this month we're limiting
this i don't care what the number is
i really don't as long as you're not
going into debt to do it
you just but you can't just be going
i'll just be okay
i'll out or no no you have to have a
number then we're both in agreement
you'll be fine
that's all you got to do to fix this
it's not how much you're spending
it's the fact that you're not willing to
put any limit on it at all
this is the ramsey show
[Music]